thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video the first 1000 people to use the
link in the description
can watch my course and thousands of
others with a free trial of skillshare
premium
during recessions consumer behavior
tends to change in fairly predictable
ways
the hardest hit businesses are of course
the most
unnecessary travel and tourism leisure
and hospitality
and manufacturing other companies
actually stand to benefit
like fast food stomachs don't respond to
economic downturns
but smaller bank accounts do opt for
cheaper alternatives
which is why chains like burger king and
wendy's often perform better than
average during recessions
from 2008 to 2010 for example while
other businesses closed or downsized
subway added nearly 6 000 new locations
kfc added around 300 in roughly the same
period
one company however stands out as the
clear fast food winner of 2008
mcdonald's that year it continued its
55-month
long streak of same-store sales
increases with even better performance
than before the recession
while opening 600 new locations and with
an impressive
29 return on equity some of this is for
obvious reasons
during that time consumers were simply
eating cheaper food
but there's another reason mcdonald's is
what some analysts call
recession proof mcdonald's is first
and foremost a real estate company
glancing at its 2019 balance sheet
one number in particular should grab
your attention 39
billion dollars that's the current value
of all its property and equipment before
it reports depreciation
that would technically make it the fifth
largest real estate holder in the world
measured by total assets cover the name
mcdonald's and this might look like the
financial statement of any other boring
big name real estate developer
like burger king and subway the company
was able to grow so fast and reach
so many countries around the world
through franchising
85 of its restaurants are owned by
someone who essentially leases the
mcdonald's name and brand
in exchange for a considerable fee what
makes the company so
unique is that unlike other similar fast
food giants
mcdonald's makes the majority of its
franchise revenue from rents
not burgers to be more precise in 2019
7.5 or 64 percent of its 11.6 billion
dollars in franchise fees
came in the form of rent here's how it
works
because mcdonald's has decades of
experience buying and selling properties
it knows the precise ingredients of a
successful location
it shops around usually for
intersections between two high traffic
roads
and buy space in whichever corner has
the most parking
the ideal space is around fifty thousand
square feet
four and a half thousand for building
space the intersection should also have
traffic
lights it then buys the property with
long-term
fixed interest rates its huge existing
property holdings provided with the most
favorable deals
then when someone applies to operate
their own mcdonald's location
they sign with the company a franchise
agreement
stipulating nearly every detail of how
the business will operate
from how the burgers are cooked to the
hours of operation
for example they can only purchase from
an approved supplier
who may or may not be the best or
cheapest option
the franchisee that is the local owner
generally makes a total upfront
investment
of one to two million dollars for a
single location
including an initial down payment paid
in cash one time franchise fee of forty
five thousand dollars
and a percent royalty of every month's
revenues
these usually 20-year contracts also
have the unusual but highly
consequential stipulation
that the restaurant be located at that
specific address
the one mcdonald's the corporation just
bought
in other words mcdonald's instantly has
a tenant
and one who will always pay above market
rates
depending on the value you attribute to
good location
scouting you might characterize this as
a valuable service
or a ruthless business tactic indeed
one franchise union found that the
average franchise tends to pay an
average of six to ten percent of its
sales
and rent while mcdonald's franchisees
pay 8.5 to 15 percent
and if a location fails to perform as
expected mcdonald's can simply find a
new franchisee for that location
after the contract has expired or sell
the land to someone else entirely
likely at a significant profit so why do
franchisees agree to these stringent
requirements
simply put because it's seen as an
incredibly safe
investment the advantage of this model
is that while the absolute numbers are
abnormally large
the fees the initial startup costs and
even the annual revenues
the odds of success are relatively high
for example the average location makes
2.7 million dollars in sales every year
with a respectable but not incredible
all things considered
154 thousand dollars in final take-home
profit
but precisely because mcdonald's is so
demanding
can it be such a solid investment sure
applicants have to meet high standards
to become franchisees and
once they do they have little control
over their own business
but all these factors also reduce their
risk while
other franchises may have fewer
requirements they also come with greater
risk
the owner of a mcdonald's can be pretty
sure they're qualified for the job
have a good location and are meeting
customer standards
because otherwise they wouldn't be
allowed in the first place
mcdonald's trains its franchisees in
what it calls hamburger university
the company's internal system of
teaching business owners all the skills
and knowledge they need
for mcdonald's the benefits of owning
property are far greater than just an
additional source of revenue
it's no exaggeration to call it an
entirely different business model
it understands that real estate is a far
better business
than hamburgers the first reason is just
a function of american tax law which
offers heavy tax breaks for depreciation
even while that same property may
increase in value over time
the biggest advantage is the long-term
stability of property prices
along with walmart mcdonald's was one of
only two stocks in the dow jones
industrial average to increase in value
in 2008.
it's also one of the 60 or so members of
the so-called dividend aristocrats
stocks that have increased their
dividends annually for 25 consecutive
years
recessions are only a welcome
opportunity to buy up discounted
properties
when things are truly catastrophic like
during a pandemic
the real estate model outsources risk to
franchisees
who are contractually obligated to pay a
minimum amount of rent regardless of
sales
all of this is reflected in the upward
trend of franchised mcdonald's locations
and downward trend of the few remaining
company operated locations
if anything mcdonald's is actively
trying to remove itself from the fast
food industry
but this naturally raises a question if
mcdonald's makes a huge portion of its
profit in the form of rent
and managing real estate is a fairly
separate skill from creating new
mcthings why not split off the real
estate holdings into a new company
do that and you have a very stable
active
and profitable real estate investment
trust one
immune from the variability of fast food
and changing consumer appetites
a group of investors suggested this very
idea in 2015
the company however decided not to
believing that its property model is
what makes it
unique and that its remarkable
efficiency is a function of doing
both now that you know the secrets of
how one of the world's great companies
truly makes its money
you might be interested in putting this
new information to use with
great skillshare courses like investing
101
which teaches you the basics of how
stocks etfs and index funds
work or learn how to build a business on
youtube
starting with my new course where i
explain step by step
how i make my thumbnails and market my
videos i also give you a complete
walkthrough of how i created this
thumbnail
when you're done learn how to design the
logo with this great course on logo
design just look at the amazing things
other students have already made
skillshare is an online learning
community where you can learn
all kinds of new skills like graphic
design programming
photography and much much more usually
in under an
hour start learning today with the link
in the description
and the first 1000 people will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
where you can watch my entire course
right now